pas mon petit coeur on est samedi je
sais tu veux t'amuser rigoler mais j'ai
du travail
ah bah oui je pense jean michel meyer
moi j'ai des choses à faire en attendant
j'ai une petite surprise pour toi que tu
regardes ton clip et après on pourra
passer le week-end en soi mais s'amuser
tir voit la photo un petit kiff
je vais bosser et après je suis à toi
[Musique]
allez bien qu'on avance a peu joué une
photo s'il vous plaît bien sûr tant prix
bien merci bonjour qu'est ce que vous
auriez comme sandwich pour 2 s'il vous
plaît pour dîner
oui oui poids non conforme à des chaînes
d'information une blague mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça commentait je dors par
terre ça c'était mon lit tu dormait par
terre
il m'a regarde moi ça depuis le début du
week-end je me plie en quatre pour que
tout soit parfait pour que tes touda
nourriture d'autres ut machin voilà les
remerciements
voilà tu passes ta nuit si je puisse
voir change de chant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]